the hags are coming they're on their way
eg was with the returning stars of
scream queens at PaleyFest and we got as
much as season to scoop as we could I
love like a dark for comedy Hospital
like yeah you know Grey's Anatomy was a
little sad right that would be a fun
tease for season two right well I mean
there's a lot of stuff that I don't know
but Chanel's gonna be back as [ __ ] as
ever looking fabulous
hopefully I've kind of been wondering it
I feel she's gonna get a makeover but
I'm not really sure what that's gonna be
I've been asking Ryan but he hasn't told
me I've heard that she's she's gonna
have some sort of new love interest what
play by someone very very very handsome
we expect a lot of very strange patients
we can expect our characters interacting
with them in a very different and odd
ways we expect a lot of the same kind of
humor and a lot of the same kind of
messaging all about Esther storyline for
this next season and it is not at all
like munch
how does she fit into the hospital I
think we may have to remove the word
Dean from her moniker oh that might
explain something I hope no if I did not
a doctor she would get really emotional
about like what is your dream for Denis
in season two
one needs to get another man maybe get
back together with your aunt radware see
if we can work our thing out somebody in
like this I want to boss the ladies
around because I think I'm good at it
and I probably still have my eye on that
baby always always gonna give an eye on
saving and also I wanted to get a little
bit of revenge when everybody was so
mean to her
well apparently promise' cuz I feel like
I had PTSD when we finish the show I'm
gonna feel more at home because I love
hospitals I wanted to be a doctor before
I did this that specialize in
schizophrenia weird at like 9 years old
that was my dream but I think this is
perfect that we're gonna be in a
hospital because I love them
not in like a dark way but oh